[Musique]
maj vous êtes bien cadrer ses parfums
super c'est parfait alors j'ai pas de
qui pleut là il n'y a pas un pet de
lumière nature et j'y suis bien
bonjour aux vidéos jour et merci d'avoir
accepté cet entretien on va parler de
sexe avec vous depuis plusieurs semaines
déjà on peut lire toute une série de
reportages de témoignages de français
dont la vie de couple a un peu changé
alors il ya certains qui nous parle
d'une forme d'exutoire face au virus le
sexe ou au contraire d'autres qui nous
disent que leur libido est totalement
chute et d'autres qui vont explorer des
fantasmes face à l'ennui dans le
confinement est ce que cette période là
elle elle vous intéresse en ce que et
bouleverse ou pas d'ailleurs notre notre
rapport au sexe j'espère si elle
bouleverse notre rapport aux c'est que
mais en tout cas elle est intéressante à
observer parce que déjà elle évolue là
on voit bien là où on en est en ce
moment où au stade de du confinement on
voit qu'il ya une évolution depuis le
début c'est à dire dès les premiers
jours il ya eu une focalisation autour
de la sexualité en général en termes de
consommation de vidéos pornographiques
et qu'en terme de questionnements autour
du cou qui a lu énormément de questions
dès le début autour d'eux comment est ce
que je fais pour préserver mon couple
est ce qu'on va se séparer on dirait ya
vu un baby boom va y avoir des divorces
vraiment on parlait beaucoup de ça on y
avait aussi beaucoup de blagues sur les
réseaux sociaux je trouve autour d'eux
comment enfin là comment on va gérer la
frustration
et j'ai l'impression que ça se passe
c'est à dire il ya eu il ya eu ce je
pense peut-être cette que sais-je pape
sy met donc je vais faire de la petite
comptoir mais cette confrontation à
l'idée de la mort qui à mon avis dans un
premier temps fait qu'on s'est focalisée
autour des questions de sexualité notre
première notre première question s'était
pas est-ce qu'on est au chômage est ce
que est ce qu'on va perdre notre travail
est ce que ça va être est-ce qu'on va
perdre nos proches savent être comment
je vais faire peut baiser voilà et là je
constate quand même hein
un tassement autour de ces questions là
déjà parce que pour un certain nombre de
couples le confinement a fait ressortir
je dirais pas des difficultés mais je
dirais carrément des des situations
vraiment très problématique voire
toxiques puisque là on se retrouve
confiné on est tout le temps ensemble
alors on parle beaucoup des disputes qui
éclate mais on a parlé quand même pas
mal des violences conjugales mais on
parle finalement assez peu des violences
sexuelles c'est à dire qu'on parle des
violences au sein du couple mais l'hôte
et en violences sexuelles le terme viols
etc il est très peu prononcé je trouve
alors que pourtant c'est sans que c'est
la suite logique de ces violences là
c'est à dire concrètement à l'heure
actuelle on a certains couples qui sont
enfermés ensemble avec l'impossibilité
de s'extraire de du lieu de vie
d'habitude il ya le travail il ya des
activités qui permettent de mettre une
certaine distance giraud sein du coup là
il ya des femmes qui se retrouvent
consignes et avec parfois un homme qui
peut avoir
des besoins je n'aime pas ce terme mais
je dirais des exigences en tout cas
sexuelle et se mélange à sains en plus
le besoin de briser la routine qui
encore une autre injonction qui vient
s'ajouter à ces dons qu'il ya cette idée
que voilà il va falloir essayer de
nouvelles choses donc ça peut être une
pression supplémentaire pour les couples
qui vivent déjà l'un sur l'autre toute
la journée mais disons que voilà je
pense à mon avis que le confinement
faire ressortir
ce genre de crispation sexuelle qui
existait déjà à mon avis au sein des
couples et qu'il a doit être
complètement exacerbée et puis il ya
aussi des couples qui se sont rencontrés
dans le confinement secteur des sites de
rencontres ont explosé pendant la
période ça donne forcément lieu à une
sexualité à distance une sexualité
médiatisé numérique fait d'écran faite
d'image faite de mots aussi c'est
réjouissant ça ou c'est plutôt triste ni
l'un ni l'autre en fait c'était déjà là
finalement quand on y réfléchit le
confinement il exacerbe un certain
nombre de choses qui étaient déjà bien
installée c'est à dire mon équipe de
rencontres ou des applications on n'a
pas attendu le confinement pour faire
fonctionner kinder quoi concrètement
sait déjà c'est notre mode de rencontre
actuelle donc ce type des changes sans
concrétisation nécessaire de d'un acte
sexuel derrière c'était déjà en place
donc je je suis pas sûr que le
confinement change grand-chose
grand-chose à ça après ce qui est
intéressant de voir c'est comment
certains couples qui était déjà
dysfonctionnelle vont vraiment mettre un
terme à la relation avec les dix ans
parce qu'il y avait des il est certain
on était un certain nombre je dirais à
avoir été dans une relation où
l'habitude faisait qu'on se sépare et
pas tout à fait et parfois la mise à
distance
du au confinement fait que ben a passé
un mois un mois et demi deux mois on se
rend compte finalement qu'on n'a pas
besoin de l'autre et convient très bien
par soi-même ya peut-être des gens qui
vont se dire j'ai pas besoin de lui
bougeait pas besoin d'elle et finalement
je je m'aime et je vis très bien par moi
même alors il ya eu une annonce qui a
été faite celle-là c'était au tout début
du confinement et est là elle a fait
beaucoup réagir sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est la gratuité des plateformes de
vidéos pornographiques
qu'est ce que vous en avez pensé alors
en réalité le porno est déjà gratuit sur
toutes ses plateformes là l'écrasante
majorité du porno aujourd'hui est
consommée sur des plateformes gratuites
je crois que c'est 95% de la
consommation mondiale du porno qui passe
par ces plateformes gratuites donc en
fait cette annonce de la gratuité
c'était juste un coup de com parce qu'en
réalité tout l'été déjà mis à
disposition il ya peut-être certaines
plateformes qui elle était payante qui
étaient minoritaires qui ont proposé je
dirais cette gratuité pour essayer
d'attirer cette population qui était à
la recherche que ce que d'habitude de
vidéos porno parce que ce qui s'est
passé dans les premiers jours je dis
bien les premiers jours de confinement
après ça s'est un peu tassé mais dans
les premiers jours de confinement il est
vraiment une hausse colossale du de la
consommation de vidéos de vidéos
pornographiques sur cette page et
regarder les chiffres c'est vrai que
c'est énorme un + 38 % pour pornhub
pour dorcel 32% de plus c'est énorme
est-ce que vous pouvez nous l'expliqué
même si effectivement ça s'est un peu
tassé par la suite ce boom des
plateformes porno qui est allée ce que
ça vient combler est ce que des gens ont
découvert le porno je crois pas que des
gens aient découvert le porno parce
qu'en fait le porno concrètement on sait
maintenant statistiquement tout le monde
en consomment dans tous les pays y
compris où c'est interdit donc cette
consommation elle était déjà très
présentes on était déjà à peu près à 300
à 350 milliards de connexions par an sur
les vidéos pendant qu on était déjà
voilà tout le monde en consommaient déjà
néanmoins on sait voilà qu'il ya une
augmentation cette consommation est dans
les premiers jours déjà peut-être pour
dissiper une forme d' angoisse la
masturbation ça dissipe une forme d'
angoisses mais aussi parce que encore
une fois il ya eu cette focalisation
autour de la question sexuelle au début
dans ce moment de confrontation à la
mort quoi finalement c'est je pense je
pense que ça a été juste une réflexion
et réaction un peu un peu humaine mais
ce qui est intéressant de constater
quand même c'est que malgré cette
augmentation des de la consommation de
porno l'industrie du porno elle même n'a
pas gagné plus d'argent c'est à dire il
ya eu un certain nombre de travailleuses
du sexe donc des actrices des call girls
qui ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé sur
les réseaux sociaux en disant nous
n'avons plus de sources de revenus
donc c'est c'est assez c'est assez
paradoxal c'est assez paradoxal parce
que la plupart de ces vidéos consommées
sur ses plates formes à son des vidéos
piratées gratuite et cetera et cetera
donc c'est les travailleuses du sexe qui
elles sont douze chaînes quoi sont des
prolétaires de ce milieu on va dire elle
ne touche pas de reversions là dessus
donc elles sont de fait en souffrance
durant cette période de confinement vous
savez si l'industrie du porno a dénié
certains pays qui
ne l'utilisait pas du tout ou très peu
est ce que certains continents on sait
ça ou pas
il me semble d'accord toujours d'après
les chiffres des plateformes donc encore
une fois prendre avec des pincettes que
aujourd'hui le porno est accessible
partout dans le monde y compris dans des
pays où la loi est censée l'interdire
donc il ya eu vraiment une
par une mondialisation de la part de
l'afld s'est finalement d'ailleurs c'est
assez intéressant de constater à quel
point ce bordeaux se consomme dans tout
l'est tous les pays toutes les cultures
alors que lui-même ne représente qu'une
seule forme de culture c'est à dire
souvent une culture
américaine ou alors on sait que la
plupart des dépendants aux pinsons
tournée en europe de l'est avec
certaines représentations aussi physique
je pas des défis blanche mince et cetera
on est dans une certaine représentation
de la sexualité qui est consommé partout
tout le monde assez c'est assez ça c'est
assez intriguant aussi de voir comment
il ya cette normalisation au tour des
des pratiques sexuelles qui s'opèrent
partout dans mon fief finalement tout le
monde vaffi pas avoir la même sexualité
de fait avec cette influence des images
vous pensez que la représentation et
uniformiser de la sexualité via ces
sites là au fond vient uniformiser aussi
nos fantasmes ou pas mais il me semble
qu'il ya eu de fait une uniformisation
de nos fantasmes qui s'est installée ces
dernières années et qui est lié à la
démocratisation je dirais de du porno de
l'hyperaccessibilité aux vidéos sur les
plates formes gratuites mais pas que les
codes qui sont en apparence anodin
pornographie en réalité sont repris
partout dans l'ensemble de notre culture
et côte du porno il se retrouve dans la
télé réalité ils se retrouvent dans la
publicité il se retrouve chez les
kardashian enfin je veux dire que kanye
west quand même il était là aujourd'hui
il chante et langil mais il ya encore un
an et demi il était quand même directeur
artistique des ports and a whole world
faut pas l'oublier ça donc on est quand
même cette corne culturel existe bien au
delà des frontières du porno donc de
fait sa une influence sur nous ce qu'on
voit dans les séries dans les pubs ça
une influence sur nous donc évidemment
que c'est qu'au delà ils ont fini par
rentrer dans notre intimité et ce qui
est assez intéressant c'est qu'il se
passe la même chose un truc avec les
régimes c'est à dire des régimes on sait
tout ça bien le contrôle du corps des
femmes et cetera et cetera il n'empêche
qu'on va quand même d'aller faire notre
petit régime quand le printemps arrive
même si on sait d'où vient cette
mécanique mais il se passe la même chose
avec les codes du porno c'est à dire et
les codes autour des sexualité en
général c'est à dire 11 ya on sait d'où
ça vient épilation intégrale à terrasser
mais finalement ça va quand même rentrer
dans notre intimité parce que on our à
comment dire intégrer vraiment tous ces
codes même si on les aura pensé c'est
assez compliqué de se déconstruire quand
même il ya eu un usage plus important
plus intensif au départ même si ça s'est
un peu tassé vous pensez que bon ça va
accélérer
les comportements à la sortie ça va
changer quelque chose véritablement
d'avoir été enfermé comme ça partout sur
la planète un peu plus de deux mois
honnêtement je pense pas que de moi ce
soit suffisant pour changer radicalement
nos sexualités le rapport à l'intimé le
rapport au corps de moi c'est pas
suffisant peut-être que ça va changer un
peu nos habitudes de connexion c'est à
dire ceux qui vont devoir retourner au
travail et qui pendant un confinement
s'ennuyer et se connecter 50 fois par
jour on devoir changer leurs habitudes
de connexion mais c'est valable pour les
réseaux sociaux pour des jeux vidéo pour
autre chose c'est ses beauty c'est pas
la pornographie qui crée la diction
c'est plutôt l'outil le téléphone
portable donc il ya peut-être des choses
comme ça qui ont changé mais sur les
rapports hommes femmes je crois pas je
pense que quelque chose a été déjà en
train de s'opérer
et il va juste perdurer bien au delà du
confinement alors justement sur les
rapports hommes femmes
quand ces verrous du confinement vont
sauter quand vous voyez les choses
est-ce qu'on va se jeter les uns sur les
autres dans une une forme voilà de dorgy
de sexe est ce qu'on aura envie de se
toucher de s'étreindre ou au contraire
paris et de normes du porno tout à
l'heure il ya une forme de normes qui
est en train d'être intériorisé dans ce
confinement la distanciation sociale une
espèce de peur de l'autre et donc on
prendra son temps avant de faire de
grandes retrouvailles je sais pas déjà
je connais je sais pas ce qui va se
passer mais je
suis pas certaine qu'on se rejettent les
uns sur les autres ou alors peut-être le
premier jour de deuxième jour mais pas
pas à long terme
ça peut-être j'ai mis une hypothèse
peut-être que le confinement pour
certains et certaines d'entre nous nous
ont amenés déjà à repenser notre
existence en ce moment c'est vrai qu'on
parle beaucoup du monde d'après du monde
d'avant marque quand même une scission
une cassure on se posait la question de
commandes à consommer à l'avenir
peut-être que ça va nous amener aussi à
nous poser la question de comment on va
consommer entre guillemets de sexe à
l'avenir aussi comment est-ce qu'on va
continuer
ce fonctionnement la même c'est de
consommation de porno en ligne peut-être
qu'il ya des gens qui vont se dire oui
peut-être que finalement je ferais mieux
de consommer pendant un film plus
éthique ou ce genre de choses on sait
pas ce qu'est ce que vous voulez dire
par pornographie les tickets ce qui
serait souhaitable de serre et
pornographique il passe pas par des
sites je dirais qui frisent avec
l'illégalité qui ne respectent pas le
droit à l'image qu'ils ne mettent pas en
ligne des vidéos qui rate et qui ne met
pas en ligne des vidéos de revenge board
des sites sur lesquels on trouve pas de
vidéos avec des mineurs ce qui est quand
même le cas on sait maintenant que
certaines plate forme panoramique qui
ont pignon sur rue qui font des grands
communiqué de presse régulièrement
équivalent certains chiffres et on sait
bien que certaines vidéos de rubens porn
avec des adolescentes trail nature merci
beaucoup merci à vidic mais là d'avoir
répondu à nos questions et à bien à
bientôt
[Musique]